classically remembers for cleansing
extremely amazing to start arranging the
emergency evacuation announcement in the
event of fire or other emergency clean
executed in an orderly manner to the
assembly point anticipated the market
Karpov fire exits in this region
indicates auditorium flags done
please do not generate evacuation by
collecting any belongings do not use the
list the premises must not be reacted
until the fire brigades are giving them
clear please know if it gives a lot of
smoke of these premises
they've also note that this meeting will
be also recorded none please requests
that members have returned off to their
my proposal thank you very much
item one of the agenda apologies absence
in politics really counselor zeal and
counsel web substituting we have seen
them now the closest very own Council
approved on music in somewhere
item two only generates non-members
second
item number three minutes of the meeting
held important March 28th we have an
amendment follically transcribed
anomalies the CNC actually safe watching
what didn't come from our thinking it's
not relented on here so I have to
support that point telling because I
also made a made a statement which is
not recorded either so if one is
material so as the other
calcium's lengthen
for the minutes which Alice
read-throughs determined and that we
agreed that they would please do okay
did that start that night to this way
remembers in Fremont that
sorry
sothanks financing that capital of leave
a comment in your causing that at that
point is argued well to the vegetation
those I mean what I did and I'm sure
that the recording will bear this out
but I require reflected upon what had
been said and I noted that in
pre-meeting the majority of members had
felt that what the Chairman had say
during the meeting was in accordance
with their understanding and wishes I
think if we go back to that recording
it's pretty close in whereas law baptism
is a lifetime not available anywhere
else
and there's our agreement that thank you
very much darling
right another fourth to see the
equations of interest
in declare effect and our instead of
moving on to arson fires confusion
lifestyle we are moving item number 11
to the desert contact the next part
terminator screen out regarding
exclusion and present public mins and
public following report contains dense
information I would therefore ask as you
know even leading consumer most of that
under Section 108 for those government
advertisers to probably excluded with
ability to the following item physics
and gravity involved like exposure
exempt information as defined in
paragraph three five one
schedule 12 I II or bf
Michael our members to look to revisit
the agenda we are back on tools and
title 5 which is the huge loss old
McCaffrey interim by coalbed link
individual business anger and John
Richardson police contact manager kind
of coalition template general manager
will be given a presentation for them to
clean them and we have had copies or
harmful begins before so some a better
chance to have a look different if I've
had over Jesus excuse your presentation
and it may be art with some question
that in fountains they get technology
lighting and killing Charlton catalyst
thank you for the opportunity to be here
this evening to present our review the
in 2015
twisting things reportedly
I'm currently encasing we didn't know
bill Richardson is the contract manager
I have delighted to so many people who
come to the curves that we did around
the center's and hopefully the
information we presented see if it can
help support those services these are
the topics that we will cover this
evening and the end of presentation
obviously we would be delighted to
answer in your questions I thought it
would be useful to show you the team
that is in Rockford and look at their
directly manages the the census on on
your behalf
I've had a very long association with
Rockford having commenced my career with
rocks with district council back in 1978
and there I was working at the Park
School Center in Rayleigh and a great
way to install the center sadly however
those are absolutely in existence by
open example to do ones that was and
I've worked in English cities in
Bradford at one time or another with
four different organizations as quasi
Rockford circulator Home Slice
and now fusion I've also been involved
in every major development of leisure
within the district and that obviously
the building a fence Hall which is
probably the main one but also elected
design team for the right laser sensor
when I was behind splice I lived in the
district for 37 years and only moved
away recently and we retain many family
and friends in the district and in the
area my reason that is saying that you
that I'm very passionate about measure
in the district are grown up with it and
they've been branded for much of my
working right and I'm determined to make
sure that we deliver first-class service
for the council
deserve to cut are neatly financed to
start with and sensitivity to to 2016 we
increase the revenue by around two
hundred thirty to three thousand pounds
the the main areas that we take the
revenue from within the sentences is on
the membership side and as a single
activity swing school remember of other
activities that are built into those the
other numbers those are the key keep to
keep income numbers but obviously as you
would expect
clémence all provides the majority of
the revenue and railey the next highest
revenue generator
in terms of participation we were
slightly up in in chemical terms of
participation slightly down in in
Braille and the reason for that is
during 2015 the main competitor
embezzlement with airlift Center was
closed for refurbishment and Rainey saw
an upturn
at that time people then returned back
to that facility once it was real but we
are seeing safety nets and increases on
premise more
as a positive increases in the target
participation groups for in the district
with the exception of the women and that
was largely down to reduce numbers that
we had within the class program
particularly clemens hall where we had
to reduce some of the numbers because
problems we've had with the flooring
within within one of the studios and
also with the gas we had to close down
some of the facilities when the gas was
also that other caused a slight decrease
but even something is to concern to us
so we're already seeing those numbers
now that everything is back working
properly we're already seeing those
numbers grow again in quite considerably
here with a venue of occupancy that
that's likely next Milton castle Racine
impressed priest occupancy and afraid
house you've seen reduced occupancy and
Frank house that was particularly set up
and had a lot of meetings with including
that facility and a lot of local
authority Health Authority most of the
meetings a lot of those during the week
that there's been a really dramatic
decline on those the number of meetings
a number of activities that those sort
of authorities have been doing within it
within the center and that's that has a
main impact on our participation the
occupancy in it one thing we are doing
we're just we're just apply for a
license factual hold weddings of right
house so that we can offer the complete
package and that we're doing which one
we're hoping then to see that increase
occupancy again
I mentioned that membership in swim
school to the key drivers in terms of
the activities we have and there's many
good causes performance Riley and the
sliding with slight increases and so the
slight beep grace at clinics that was
due really juice the opening of the
exercise for less which you may be aware
of in in Rockford which took slightly
takes the members but now we're seeing
the return back to to tenants they offer
a single activity which is a gym whereas
obviously we were able to after a great
wider selection an activity that started
from regrowing
we engaged in a company called market
force to undertake and quest data for us
on behalf of us provide customers and
you will see there that we've increased
the number of returns we've had by six
hundred and fourteen prompt to 2050 it's
key to get as much of that as possible
in order to make it so it's relevant and
from that you can see that the
complaints are down the compliments are
up and suggestions received are up so
those are trends that we wanted to
maintain and the more proactively we can
increase that line really in terms of
these information getting back to all
relevant it is we also engage life puts
together the Net Promoter Score chorus
if you know the score now that a number
of businesses using and it's based on
one single question how likely are our
customers to recommend us to friends or
colleagues so it's a very simple very
simple question and the Net Promoter is
the percentage of the promoters - the
percentage of detractors and within the
business we have a target of 30% on them
well that's relatively high if you take
all the industries and all the different
industries that use this NPS score and
we're delighted with with the
performance in Rockford and we're well
above the company target with the
highest end yes we have the highest NPS
score in Rockford so we're very pleased
that that's where it is in again a
determination is to maintain that
put them in some sort of perspective we
have nineteen contracts around the
country or something like 100 centers so
it's a it's an achievement to got that
look within the industry in the things
that are business through the target of
three accidents ten thousand visits
normally we do that over a monthly basis
and then aggregate capacity that's to
say if we've only had two we don't go
and have a good hamburger so that's
that's more if we're trying to manage
down to that level and obviously it's
about pre-op proactive management and
making sure that their systems processes
and procedures help to maintain and low
level of accidents clearly any activity
in a major center there's an element of
risk we can't remove that completely but
it's about managing those risks and
management proactively
within the business we have a it's
called F 360 or fusing 360 and it's a
platform we developing we put all of our
audits on so at the moment within the
business we've got our standards audit
that takes place twice a day it's
recorded on a tablet there's a set of
questions that feeding to our online
maintenance so that here we undertake
our maintenance within Roger and it also
goes to a team so it spreads out the job
still to where there we completed we've
just now added onto that the pool
testing a critical element within the
data center and this allows us to recall
all of the core tests we either take
those every two hours and we need that
to make sure that all the safe
environment for people going see the
benefit of this is it can be reviewed by
all levels within the organization if
there's a support test miss anywhere in
the country that some people get a text
or an email to say that's been missed if
we get readings that are well outside of
the what's acceptable again there are is
a program of escalating that so the
action and that can be taken to actually
get that back into into life we are the
only company in the country that has
that system and operates that
so we're quite proud of that because
it's a really positive way of managing
the course we've just completed the
condition service survey and they just
arrived with our ESL Department and
they're now starting to review those and
look at those and it's covered Lee
Emily's got to apply across all of the
facilities in not sure
once we've analyzed those that the plan
is then to share that with your officers
will discuss that and I would call that
again in the second in terms of what we
were doing alone during 2016 we spent
around 160,000 power of the buildings
and you can see there the list of the
main headline numbers that where we went
that model and again those who play
rails 2 credits all will have seen the
extent of the guess works that we took
at that side and that's about 120,000
spent on that added to that 160 so it's
great quite considerably investment in
terms of main maintenance within the
facilities at the moment
one thing that we have been discussing
with with the offices when the council
with the job students are doing best to
say let me know that's one on the table
at the moment but we have a timetable
now that we'll be working through we
mostly completed the initial surveys we
will be assessing those and then
considering what we do and how we can do
those in the investment opportunities
and those discussing it with your
officers terms all the way forward and
then we will then go back and then we'll
look to present a list of investment
proposals to the council in June and
July so we have a timetable now in terms
of off or we'll be working to support
the investment side finally just to just
talk about another key focuses that we
have in in your district and that's
particularly around the its SSD made
small community development that's
really important that's about how we get
out into the communities and we engage
with the communities and get them in to
use the facility it's about getting more
people more active and getting them
involved one often within within the
center's and these are some of the the
activities that we've been running
during 2016 so beginning running groups
walking football when women go to
practice festival one of the most
important from this is that we don't
just do that one activity and then walk
away we get people engaged and we keep
them engaged so for example the walking
football we now have regular walking
football sessions within within the
center's and we're all we're doing those
a close at the moment we're just now
starting to do it maybe as well so it's
about getting people engaged and then
keeping them engaged it's included
we also work with a number of partners
we can't do without activity the sports
leader Colonel Anna Rose so there's a
number of different partners that we
work with because those they already in
the community there are any identify
people who may be interested or or would
like to get involved in and help the
business and leisure so we work very
closely with those and then also we are
able to source funding which helps us
then to be able to pull on some of those
activities so those are just some of the
people that we currently work with and
obviously we're all within seeking to
work with other partners doing we can
either funds or ways we can get new
activities moving forward so that's a
very very quick run-through in terms of
being the review but obviously we're
very happy to take any questions thank
you very much and some members have
indicated that they have a few questions
everybody's just from the capability
convinced our captain
their question regarding that is Thank
You mr. chairman two questions as you
want observer arising from the
presentation that whether 20 of their
ways may have given the duration of
presentation first under your posture
satisfaction surveys you put suggestions
received and improvement gaining
information some actions are getting
taken that improve gaining information
which is same what you've done for
dinner
yeah quit product if on the Sonics I
mean don't talk enough those are better
will be proactive on citing gathering at
information we making sure the firm's we
get email addresses showing people are
engaging the market force will go out
and actively get to them to provide us
with the information so it's about us
just being more variety asking customers
talking to customers getting all the
other so two sided in that so you give
information because one of the members
on the two to be couldn't see I believe
been planning to the crash so perhaps
that should be looked at to way
that is the point we must rally the
analytics let's do now is to write join
our users to do feedback so that we will
send out another invoice month to users
to be back to go to their email address
and then they invite feedback so when
we're at the trauma game for feedback or
to to improve and on that point your Net
Promoter Score first the remember
restored is $11.99 seven the upside or
coming response to the report word class
place of the live album yes thank you
welcome to mobility clear and going back
to the original question that I wanted
to our first chairman a year ago when I
went around the census we noticed there
was was an automatic capacity especially
with their talent one of the things we
suggest that I suggest eventually was
that many of us when we go to see a
doctor we've had a physical problem are
given an explanation very simple little
paper
the stretch bangor ever most people are
not able to implement those exercises
probably which they're going to it's
they're recovering and may make seven
worth and what we suggested was that
actually was a linked up between the
health service and your facilities
presume probably had trainers to offer
those classes or some sort of
instruction either directly five health
of it or directly to residents who may
have that because I think it's an avenue
that would help people that would
otherwise not coming to a big center the
evening I just come from one of with it
it would be helpful have anything we've
done the last year
I think that we're not only has to this
is because I've arrived in February and
John's been clock thank you sir thank
you so generously how about members mark
Guzman could you just a lot of uses on
one of those decide as a previous slide
around the GP referrals and that's
something that we've been looking to
improve at both the sides over some year
now and that's half way because of
getting that by first before we take it
on to any kind of you to say so we've
got some investment we're degree power
probably help improve lobster and all
their boards any transitional staff at
local sites that include surgeries that
improve as a year ago seems that we're
going to get right and then it with
something else it's about a matter that
will fire so we get that one I think it
was a quite obscure clinical technical
because the number of people that will
have hospital
the other thank you thank you there's
something we will make sure that we pick
up on with that stories but what I can
to make sure they do well to they'll
tell you is very positive the next year
or for next is take sorry Christian
thank you guys councils for using a
stock questions to me about question yes
and when I asked about Christ the Krish
in in the running maybe is quite easy to
find if the way you look in it
is spike as one of them told I by actor
us see where for there wasn't any luck
so in the money hope it's going up but
in the one pencil I just found it's
quite hard time okay we look at the
signage yeah yeah
as somebody that has built read and not
be penalized important letters across
there
can you just wear it exactly the case as
you come through the turnstiles just on
your parsley integral to the cafe and
lettuce just on your left absolutely
toilets will make sure there's better
sighs that's why I don't accept our m/m
and capital a mystifying question thank
you
people leave and I have just a couple
questions about the presentation as well
within the building servation mentioned
in your presentation the talk about
plant equipment with people with I'm not
sure where than a baby within the survey
a parent out whereabouts would things
like change your instinct when you look
at the under plastic Whitman or is that
not part of the survey such as the
website changing rooms for instance you
if that will be part in the survey so a
bolito be part server and that that's
made of data clauses and that we looked
at that's the fact that say thank you I
mean I'll move on to the participation
figures from there they always enjoy
participation because it's also I think
a mapping from some days I guess your to
the footage my apparently with within
the pot space because you go out right
now that from target wrote 60 classic
society etc of what's got a bit of
filler so about this in that we don't
we've got target group but we don't seem
to have a target or not anymore or
anything to measure ourselves against
I'm not sure
if having 50,000 under six is
participating is good or bad or how it
compares to other areas it means I've
got no idea so I don't know if we can
you can convince mark those or them well
we do with a number of steps in a group
if you have the area centers in
agreement with you again with the
council early on with the officers we
work on those numbers each year looking
to improve those numbers so if it's just
because one of my things I'm like just
improving numbers I want to know if
there if there if you can set be like
where they should be or just months if
you know where they should go don't know
yet and that's one of the problems if
we're setting to improve what I think
that's why those who are doing it that's
good
within the participation overall as well
we're giving you giving come figures
you've got to the roughly 50% is Jack
are five men which you can depend on
these results 50 setters men without
functioning opportunities membership
Russians are standard being real
interesting is communal from elsewhere
we transfuse are a footman Petrie's
things other tennis or walk or very
bitter center allergies
we've got that broken down by income but
we don't have that person down by
participation so you are the only
overall figures for participation at 606
4000 and I'll make it about ten thousand
four hundred and seventy per week for
tennis all that B then again I don't
know if that's good or bad or who's
bullying who's doing the gene whose
whose players or for opposing this
principle based on that nothing that's
what we like to know not just for the
information but know if it's actually
providing evidence what they really want
nothing else quite important
to amend sorry that we do report on that
monthly and we do break it down in here
is remember here we have remedy into
that in step that I should do we do but
is that so if I make these surveillance
members we attended yeah it meant
available formats and more also just
give it to have you interested myself
yes let me get a nothing right now and
then the middle of an idea where we are
then preserved my motto really and that
goes back to a question I asked
previously with Huijin is about the
business model and you didn't mean I
thought it as you went past in with Kwas
very quickly because I'm Mike as early
as the budget
Jim's if that means is a problem or not
my view was that maybe the lead model
that is being run by fusion the direct
debits of 40 or 50 pounds per month
exact eighty when can go to the gym for
10 15 pounds with the classics included
and probably particularly with reference
the Rayleigh dataset which doesn't have
us report by our consular only early
this year only indications are the bunch
of humans have now been operating for
year exercise class they're starting to
change their model
our customers return and we will see
their own indications of this pumpkin
corner violin together mark will show an
increase in participation again and
increase in numbers and Orkut on my head
Michael and we're good for again 60
members and that's people returning from
exercise less most budget areas because
they bunk in state service or the same
the same package there's so much in
record which I think that feels be quite
healthy for Yesenia I mean the model the
local authorities Asia has always been
the family market that's the star point
in terms of you can cater for everybody
within that market the budget gyms are
seen focus is the gym so if you've got a
partner or wife or whatever who wants to
do classes generally then they not
necessarily available we've got children
swimming that's not available in there
so and if you can get for exam have the
kids come and swimming then the parents
of all eyes come join and do other
activities so it's about us focusing on
where where we believe our business is
which has been that sort of family and
those people are with other activities
rather than just a gym you can't compete
with 9 pound 50
you know a gym membership a lot we
wouldn't even try to exactly that would
be suicidal for our business or any
business we've got like a model David
Lloyd for example continues to go after
a certain market and that level because
they know that's where their market is
they're not trying to compete with the
budget chips so you know there's
different different levels in the
marketplace different models that we
operate and we we believe we understand
our model is historical market in that
that's where we put our effort into into
those and generating business from that
and it's particularly will be around
family market and the spread of
activities thank you very much can click
one yeah question do you like that I
think yet it always laugh about very
appeals here from them from the groups
that you've identified to be given
figures they are in relation to
particular target groups and my question
revolves around people who have our
niche in that regime which would
probably be males in their teens
twenties and thirties if all the target
groups are going up of your overall
participation is down slightly in that
area must be down
by reasonable man deserve anything busy
looking to do is climb in crews and
participation back there or is that
something that you're not focusing on it
we've had experience like this project
productive colleagues funding over the
last three years
and one project now looking to introduce
with active guy and it's all that
exactly that it's not so much focus on
all these other groups that get as you
also geographers year old males probably
yes I don't grow so reasonably free
activity in one in collagen that works
out request again I can't acute
counselors Stanley you had a question
regarding and take that people it's more
for future with
yes a certain one more of having come to
your premises and notice that there
wasn't too much activity at that
particular time I wonder if you might
think about a weekly test on how how the
product is going in other words how many
people are visiting each individual work
at whether if we of the on cycles or in
the freeways or whatever you know this
at the moment this is a year of the year
and I just wonder if you could give it
might be that in some months you get
more people in and some months you want
depending on the weather conditions and
all that sort of things so with the
Prospectus of where we could go really
the future August 1 is that could be
something you can be okay
yeah I mean I mean certainly we're
monitoring on a regular basis daily
sometimes weekly but we also share the
monthly statistics with the officers
which as we were mentioning just now
where we have a much more detailed
breakdown within those rather than
justice so they come under regular extra
scrutiny you know mostly meetings for
building Lincoln's doodles really really
be beneficial things through those a
report or would you not do that I think
that's all customers were quite policy
abused and that you put in the real
world yeah I think perhaps if we work
with your offices on that we will come
with a report that meets your needs and
provides you with information because so
it's all available it's got so many
we're hiding in something just trying to
consolidate it all the annual calls are
active I can jump into it over there and
we might our special girl group exercise
classes on a weekly daily basis or your
basis that if they die under a board
underperforming we will look to a place
forward moving class or do something
different with so we look at those
statistics look at the members people
are using them weekly daily however
often we mean to because they are all
what we call kvite to certain percentage
have been doping at the city too and we
look and say well that class isn't
working we now need to put another one
since the turn of the year we've put on
a circle an additional 30 classes on a
Clemens all because there was a need
critical classes on which is therefore
then then told us that we need to change
certain brands of what we're doing to
attendance calling indoor cycle we
bought into a brand so as if there's
mill sprint and pledge comes out there
because we realize that our own branded
wasn't working so we need to win some
Tiffany
so we do that weekly on the classes
anyway mechanically and we also review
our swimming school when we need to
increase capacity system last month we
put another additional space in terms of
course it's grown to that much so I've
been growing growing month or month so
we do do that on a number of different
kpi's anyway so we do to that why we
thank you very much to remember that the
great Christian Council sure I think
you've been up directed to ask your
questions originating my question was
which is very important when we met you
said the exact sheep in order those
living within the next couple weeks and
if we came along it was in their
interest in advise taking four to six
weeks
we are losing you're losing facilities
that are disabled so this unfortunately
unfortunately I put my hands up it's a
mistake on my part that I didn't know
that the magic voice beast and Michelle
finds it so you can't go just by
hospital bills so when we placed new
order ideal I know that
it wasn't until the exact date that they
came back to me and said this is how to
imitate to build because it's a
suspicious bit of kid they don't hold
stock items now I am probably going down
that route if I don't realize that
assignment is a mistake that I made at
the time and I can't put hands on
commoditize so when can you give us a
diplomat those you're going in I can't
give you an exact date now
I can tell you within this enable the
don't could obviously this year if I
just thought of us because you know the
dates are moving honestly to look though
there are below I said what I do
apologize I can't change Y says but the
voice was ordered and it's not on the
Shelf I own your offices of had exactly
the same amount correspondence that I
had Cazale bore to build so much like I
do
and when you come running is there any
time to clean out let melodies of high
leadership thank you thank you very much
and tonight's mission is cancer Williams
though I was really surprised to see
that you can still enter the website
regularly with your street shoes on
there must be some way that this term if
you go to the guns so important out
there there are benches outside where
you can change the cross-contamination
there must be honest there could some
people be done about this
most definitely the blue shoes are made
available but I do feel we need to build
a culture of you can't
as you say going there without the
benches we can put a bench outside there
which is no problem whatsoever and it's
better policing from our part so there
is no problem with us in purchasing that
and we will do so that we know that we
will take a little over there I will
also commit to on see some better
signage because we do have in our
implement the business we do have
signage for interviews now get that make
sure that happens because that will as
your mr. quite the same in addition I
just want one on living in item number
70 ladies attending the free doctor is
on the ballot box with and yoga what do
you do for them that's very very
question I think mark has touched on our
cast articles on a bit space that we
would be doing in the future between the
guys there has been a major version
focused towards the ladies because
there's been a national campaign with
that one we can and that will be flipped
over to guys soon but big yes that's
something we
Ian can begin - okay thank you so I just
on the the OPP festival that will open
to men and women it's just that but
women that came up was that was opened
employees effort it is the CV husbands
of the operator thank you thank you
Catholic mr. Mason Thank You chairman
I'd like to last this job and call this
question it's an important question
because his members are in really
interested in it
can you give me an honest I know you've
been here since February maybe isn't
December clearly has been changes in the
team well I I wasn't expecting but
nevertheless to hear he was he had a
good look at because it's all facility
what's your open and honest and frank
appraisal of the west side changing area
in particular
in this approval in what way in
decoration in terms of lockers cubicles
that's that's what it requires and in
terms of the Paul environment itself and
you see the me premium immediate
improvement plan and it's difficult
dealing with a building that is what
forty odd plus is it of age so there are
always going to be elements within that
will need to be to be maintained so
there isn't a way of stripping the whole
thing back and starting again
so these about just keeping on top of
any way to that's required so you might
notice anything in particular that needs
to be done in the actual swim area
itself
there's nothing you've seen what a we're
going to do something around you
directly towards and I'm asking I'm
asking Logan question are you're running
like you're running here my residence it
swimming pool if it's the only public
with simpler is I have three button I'd
given feedback to that opposite I was
really very very interested as I know it
other members here are interested in
what you noticed and what you see you
need to making an immediate impact upon
and I I haven't heard you've noticed
anything in particular except you've got
to keep in touch with the maintenance
I'm going to say disappointing because I
have to be open and honest with everyone
I mean I can't do anything else
I am and in terms of the changing area
and I think that's an immediate need or
for work isn't it Peter would you agree
that without a needs investment yet
community building Ballet's there is a
continual need for investment to keep it
up to a standing there is a need for
investment within the changes there is
no doubt what are the time scale of the
CEO sack is that being enacted well
we've gotta go through the condition
service we've got into creditors and
we've got it we've got a deal with the
items within there I think you know you
need to bear in mind we've only got five
years left on the contract so we've got
to manage that within that time scale
are you telling me you don't want to
make an investment in the weaponizing
like so many ideas they're not saying
that at all but you need to take the
term of the contract when the investment
when we need it
over that time into account so I can't
look forward to a big investment in the
website climate all well I need we need
to go through the condition surveys that
we've just received to see what we're at
what we need to do what we're able to do
within the given time scale so we've got
explain to me that again so you're
saying there's only five years left and
that they're all means what's in terms
of the blessing of we there are a
variety of things we need to do within
the conditions of those and that will be
sent out so we need to make sure that
we're doing this it's been a case of and
evaluate and what else that we can do
within that time scale when you say at
the end but we do need worry I don't
understand that you can use me sorry I
think I might require your own sample
I'm going to get more content answer
that I'm very disappointed German and I
entitled I'm entitled by my position as
having been elected particularly as
Clements always in my ward to ensure
that I have the opportunity so are all
of the questions that are necessary to
ensure that residents get best value
from us which is something that our
audit committee will also be looking at
nobody's so but you think this evening
we are we are push the time huh
absolutely another member that want to
ask questions German I'll ask the
question about adding value investment
the profile for come at all I'm getting
no answers and you're not letting me the
serious thank you you're welcome I
excited to see that milites okay on a
question and now from Kelso dry cleaners
Chairman's advice talk about why this is
important with our next the castle
facility now summer was there it was in
desperate need of professionals happen
to it since it only plans to this
function and is the take-up increasingly
one of the one of the things that we
have completed ask us come the months
we've asked for summer sponsor is little
that could possibly take up in your
concerns going to try to obviously
increase to increase that one of the
things we looked at is some chair based
exercises go into there something you
uses is before things like the GP phone
sessions so people who can't necessarily
get those centers because it's quite a
local hub and if ideal for somebody a
lot of people probable access to
vehicles and I want to get
etc etc so that is really contain
capsule to those things so we're
actively putting these local trying to
get these local groups to come into New
Zealand with the mill the active the
active group for now but they're they're
looking to put some classes on in there
locally for all the residents there it
has been some work done if you cancel
what I've done haven't for detail and I
and there has been an increase over to
you
Thank You members but it may not signal
give it we have raised a lot of
questions following this presentation we
are unfortunately also enough to give
everybody an all time really definite
amount of time that just isn't possible
so for now the first presentation
answering questions on presentation
again tonight because we have asked our
prior holder and officers say the mind
after this to go back and read it and
I'm sure there will be more questions
because individual contract and so far
the top half the move to thank you both
for sympathy presentation do not get
implication
I think embers meeting to come back into
Paisley Park in new public meeting now
and the back to the agenda vitamins 6
which is the interactive business plan
you can hear from answer our system dr.
green services and assistance of counsel
mr. Mason regards the interactive
members and limited the informant
program program has been set up to and
support this delivery of the business
plan and the projects that are
comfortable for that business and
decisions at work and that group
consists of myself
it has calm very handsome
the companies I love them in abundance
so remember the house amazing
our support and
and through the work of the earth and
oxidants deliver those projects coming
forward any systems you can we so I've
given many marvelous and one of the
projects we do as a program started in
photography their interactive business
time taken place and we basically have
created linkages but I don't know
do you own a second YUM
yes I mean how crazy things subscribe to
the program office has decided to look
closer and with the interactive me and
Angela to look at the website generated
by Beasley go of it looking at the
travel industry and how to make an iron
in volume is complete remember focus
group if I could just hand over to
encounter movie the the reason that I'm
involved with this project is because
the program office is overseen by my
klepto who is the chair as the
investment board and under the terms of
the program office is a project I
support Mike Steptoe and in this
particular project I've been delegated
to to support the offices
Carrie Harbor is the architect of what
we currently have as a prototype
interactive business plan now I never
fool around the table I know that when
we offered a investment board training
session we a lot of members came along
they were there in the investor board or
not and if you remember Jerry had four
or five laptops dotted around the room
and you won't have the opportunity to go
and have a play and that's exactly what
we're talking about what we're talking
about is the business plan which is even
on the wall it's actually mounted look
at this this time sets out what our main
priority activities are and they give
headlines to the major projects there's
Angeles it we have maximizing assets by
good fortune we have man here and we
also have met here with project Wireless
and to know what's going on in those
projects you have to probably go and ask
questions and I know if I want to know
something about project either or the
investment board does then we ask that
to give us a copy of the of the project
plan and an investment board meetings
we've started to ask at the end of the
meeting to have update reports on
various projects and that's because we
don't have a very easy way of actually
having a day-to-day opportunity to find
out to know what's going on
this interactive business plan is it's
an electronic model it takes the
business plan it identifies the projects
and it drills down it's a bit like when
you're surfing the internet when you
surf the internet you find a navigation
point on a website and you simply drill
down to what you want to read and find
out about
the way this interactive businessman
currently works is it works through
Excel it works through hyperlinks that's
known to most people around the table
you are linking and you can get down to
the individual documents about the
project and how it's going there's any
one snag in this and it's a snag that we
can overcome is that obviously some
information is on purple paper and we
wouldn't want that to be outside of our
internet so when we start thinking about
how we can make it accessible we have to
consult with the public which is part of
this this projects own consultation so
the residents focus group is looking at
is this a good thing will residents be
interested in being able to look at our
business plan to be able to drill down
into it and find out what they want to
know about what the council is doing in
its major activities for future proofing
the council or even just improving
services for that matter because not
every project as an IV project from my
point of views remember I would love to
have access to it I'd love you know I'd
love to be able to take hold of the
business plan and I'd like to be able to
see what were your projects are doing
how they're getting on are they meeting
their milestones when are they going to
complete are we and how was that
that milestone preceded what happened
about that that presentation from wing
range of Jacob Jacob's for instance on
the coastal files project it also I'd
have to ask you about or stop enough
Matt about or something that to ask me
about in the projects I'm running I'm
very supportive of using technology in
the right places I would like this to
have
- board I would like this dashboard to
be available to strictly to senior
officers because it gives them the
opportunity receive each other are doing
and how they can help each other and of
course it helps staff see overall what's
happening without having to visit a
project individually for the residency
will give them a certain amount of
assurance that not everything is in
exempt and they can see what's going on
and for members I think that's vital -
so I'm when here is a an advocate for
the project it's got to the point where
Terry Harper is retirement so we have a
prototype there's a number of ways we
can go about seeing it delivered as a
project in due course it's something we
could deliver internally it's something
we might find software externally from
the council but first we need to hear
from residents we need to hear from the
staff and we need to hear from members
so those of you who've played with the
front end if you like the drill down you
know something about it already
for those of you haven't then the
opportunity is to ask Angela before
Terry goes to you to get a chance to do
it but otherwise what in this particular
item on the agenda we're asking views
anyone any clients or question can still
claim you say that Manny's can't with
the idea and the structure of the whole
thing retiring who is going to be the
person who's going to carry this forward
in that well we do have more than one
Excel spreadsheet expert I don't
remember a name I met a once take a ride
in and she'll be taken into this project
it is in itself format so obviously this
if weepy but come back to be useful
tools or information has visible either
are the other members or you probably be
moving waiting yet they are made people
was more high-tech eyes met and we need
to know whether
cancel whether it's just so having
attended the Investment Board meeting
and having had a plane on the prototype
as I was very impressed to that
particular range of projects that have
been developed through the investment
board together actually looked at the
the paid for each of those projects then
to drill down and disclose information
and available agent managed very useful
the in similar could private employment
licenses there's a lot of potential
there so I certainly recommend American
team developing at council point can
potentially the June yes on we didn't go
to the training session well at least I
don't remember going to a few money I
think the various being so it's one fish
most of them some officers recently what
projects are how are you on going and
controlling and warehouse we are with
them so one person in five areas but
also on the contact you'll be as well
here we can arrange learning
whether workers can be like another
completely I think it's a great idea
important own their words have a handle
on what's happening because the
investment world and the general public
as well
NC item I'm sure there will be other
culture I think it's a good an amazing
idea
I can tell a lot that when we went to
the training money very good I know
oh it was a prototype with loud music in
certain things my sponsors would be a
very useful tool to be on to use to see
what projects are going on various like
the counselor drive it goes beyond the
investment bankers as council make
making plays I said I think everything
isn't on the investor boys not quite a
lot which is including you so even some
night agendas on the investment board
doesn't know generally things go student
whatever with regard to pay indeed what
will happen they're just not appear or
is it to something some indication that
there or something that you can for you
sorry oh no great you're one the links
just that member will everything to our
main contention area
and we can create a password protected
document open any pmc documents
thank you I think please we should
welcome anything that you hold in
transparency for all members and when to
the topic the only thing I would like to
feel the group giving out that
information members may have queries or
questions that we want to raise I and so
might members the public so what I would
like to say that that if it is possible
under the model you're looking at is
that for it appeared there is a contact
we have a contact name or a phone number
so that if it were months that a staffer
the question that isn't covered by this
drop-down menu is assessable and isn't
PLC in course and certainly for members
it members want to perhaps give some
input because they're looking at it and
saying okay absolutely something we
should reconsider I think we need to be
openness to go both ways that I need to
inform but to receive information so is
that possible isn't it do you have the
office
like on that general
I think it should be a contact any
questions on this to take that openness
and that transparency to the way we're
giving information also the council
there was the work for me to receive
information so subject and that slight
suggestion I think it's brilliant idea
they even come back and pay back to my
college and Angelo in working with the
resident group
the things we generally close okay thank
you very much to calculate and Adam
thank you enjoy
okay you can remember
item number seven o'clock everybody got
copied to handle that one it will be out
for degree people false world including
its opponent that is for money but in
England an empowerment
one incredible item all right keep
seeing darkness and 12:16 will sweep the
enforcement policy and that's been on
there for a number of months move in
December and I wouldn't be surprised if
it moves again on the next one that
issue at the moment especially 31st of
March I took on that nothing came out
today so and then 3:17 the annual
establish contact
it's also on their last month and it's
just the compliance of new legislation
that's coming out of law school so see
now remember yes
yeah you signed up for your member
cazilou sanded off commercial decline
tea okay and the last one which is a new
one for 17 environmental health service
plan 2017 to 18 now this is an annual
one and Mendes might remember I think it
was general to the line in this year
that they had the presentation so you
will know what what it's all about
we saw one another presentation I will
clear in their workspace we're going to
kingdom number 8 - World Bank
there are names of a copy of the work
plan for Jenna clapping punish their
compensation and share difficulty like
and as for yes okay and normally some of
the projects would have finished that
they're kind in fact all three are
carrying on and review the Constitution
army team an anointing revival in the
treasury management project will need
the following week and the icing team
review met last week and it just comes
short time that all I want to
they are all of the items that haven't
been consistent this year and they'll be
carried either
to select those topics they want to
pursue okay moving on to indices and
manami annual report everybody all
members should have had a [ __ ] email
trypsin quickly able to a chance to have
a look at that some reviews many numbers
remember while making changes or just
beneath additions or losers
do you have to include what we've just
done your lips really pivotal on the
ledger
yeah yes I can put a paragraph in on
that we go you yes thank you can type
the capital one okay breathe it just
trying to think is not to remember in
the sanctuary housing yep once didn't
stating there that that is going back to
full council it's exactly so hope we
could recognize I receive the
presentation from the same tree but you
know what
you certainly what would the impact be
on the annual report you can't we can't
say what's going back for council rumor
say something thanks for what Jenna no I
wouldn't I wouldn't not downtown subway
for asking for a reference to be made to
the fact that sanctuary were invited in
gave a presentation on their plans
development plans I would not lie down
at all it is a fact it's important yes I
didn't know to thank you you can say
recommendations when they don't answer
they okay what they are just
recommendations and I can answer it was
happy pedestrian show that we actually
doing something that canceled it let's
go see
any other food calculation I think one
thing that we mentioned is the method of
a special power holders that offices
should things be acquitted and I think
that structures being chased a lot so
I'd like to say that reaching out so
that there is a clarity cult members
yeah I can recommend a photographer
certain understand the gospel so again
in an understand works all right
can't serve the first initial change in
the past what we did was ask the doctors
to enjoy
other countries etc announce formally
diagnosis and both are developed in
writing the Constitution a constitution
which is exactly yeah we should probably
always say that I have nothing to change
promise being speaking to it I don't
think with workplace we've done for
somewhere so we're just our final
situation so that ISM no understanding
going forward which is that one I just
people on the correct way when I chair
the country you'll be done again
correctly over anything else members
have questions okay awesome temperaments
have been going so that a lot of
meetings